my Lumia 950 artists big break on the
Disney Channel original movie zombies he
then went on to take the world by storm
even making it to the 2018 semi-finals
of Dancing with the Stars pretend things
you didn't know about Milo Manheim keep
on watching
Milo Manheim is an undeniably talented
star on the rise but for some people he
is only known for his role on Dancing
with the Stars if you're a true fan of
the star you know that there is so much
more to him than just his on-screen town
have you ever wondered where my Lois
before his big on-screen debut will be
sure to keep on watching because I've
got the answers for you right here in
this video and more Milo started the
career he asked today at the old
fashioned way hard work
Milo's advice for his young fans looking
to get into acting is to just keep doing
what you love and something good will
happen according to the actor he didn't
go out looking for the role at all he
just did what he loved to do at the age
of just 7 Milo was already working on
his craft in an after-school program in
Culver City before making his big
on-screen debut in 2009 Milo had already
appeared in 20 different musicals one of
these musicals includes the rock musical
rent this role would play a pivotal part
in kick-starting Maya's career since
this is where acting director amber
Warren first noticed the star it was
born who helped him land his role on a
Disney Channel original movie
zombies and it's safe to say we are all
eternally grateful for that one Milo is
the only son of award-winning actress
Cameron Mantha
he spent much of his time behind the
camera watching his mother on the set of
Ghost Whisperer and the practice
according to an interview with the
actress that sparked his interest in
becoming a director giving him a genuine
appreciation for his craft now would you
believe it if I told you that Milo is
not the first man I'm on the Disney
Channel it's true guys Milo's mother was
also a Disney Channel star herself
ringing any bells yet be sure to hit
that pause button we give me your best
guess in the comments section below she
starred on none other than the hit
series Hannah Montana
playing Margot Michaela's manager it's
no wonder that Milo's all-time crush is
Makayla herself or as we know her Selena
Gomez
now despite being an only child Milo is
rarely alone
he is always surrounded by some awesome
friends and even lovers while Milo has
seated many beautiful women he is said
to have the most chemistry with his
co-star meg Donnelly there is no denying
that the two would make for an amazing
couple but don't just take my word for
it
according to Meg the two hit it off or
right away when it came to on-screen
chemistry tests they were initially not
paired together but hanging out and
talking the entire time these two were
clearly destined for love at least on
screen Milan was born on March 6 2001
making Marlowe star sign of Pisces
Pisces are known to be selfless and
always willing to help the people they
love they make for awesome friends who
will always be there for you when you
need them and try and make you laugh you
no matter the situation they are also
known to be very artistically talented
which Milo's definitely is not only is
he great at singing and acting but he
can also play a ton of instruments like
the piano the guitar the drums and even
the ukulele Milan started dating holiday
Kriegel in 2018
he started off the year by posting a ton
of cute photo of the pair to his
Instagram account Holliday is an actress
herself starring alongside milo in the
production of Chicago and even dabbling
in the world of modeling the two really
made their relationship Instagram
official when they posted the pictures
of their brontë of it unfortunately for
the fans who shipped the two together it
seems as though Milo and Holliday have
broken up at least for now don't be too
upset though because this does mean that
our boy Milo is now back on the market
remember when I told you that my lowest
surrounded by some awesome friends well
some of those friends include the car
Jenner clamp in an interview with j14
magazine
Milo explains that he first became
friends with the family teaching them
how to play poker
Kim Kendall and even Chris tweeted their
support for Milo on his time at Dancing
with the Stars now for some fun facts
about Milo Milo is a pretty tall dude
measuring it six foot two
with a foot size of 13 his favorite
actor is Jim Carrey's his favorite
beverage coca-cola his favorite TV shows
ours doc Stone is gonna be famous
a good place and the office his favorite
candy bar its KitKat his favorite food
sushi to get to know my little more be
sure to check out his channel at Milo
and Mason have similar you de Milo you
should re-watch the fun 5 section and
give yourself a point for each
similarity starting with your favorite
actor your favorite food and leaving
yourself a score out of 5 in the comment
section below
Milo enjoys playing a ton of sports like
soccer volleyball and even water team
making it no surprise that he was able
to keep up with his Dancing with the
Stars partner Witney Carson when he's
not starring in movies
he's cheering on his favorite sports
teams this includes the Lakers the
Dodgers and the Green Bay Packers when
asked of Milo e do if he wasn't acting
he says he would love to be a chef his
favorite pastimes include watching
videos of Gordon Ramsay on YouTube a guy
who can sing dance and cook sign me up
if you hadn't had enough of Milo and
McDonnell E's on-screen chemistry be
sure to check out their reunion on
American housewife Milo makes an
appearance on the ABC drama as character
peers who wants to be a lot more than
just friends with Meg's character Felix
there's just one problem she's already
got a boyfriend if you haven't already
be sure to check out the episode to find
out what happens between the two and
that is all we have time for today
thank you for watching guys and see you
next time on the things
[Music]